welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and spoilers ahead for Ant-Man of
the ones Guana media because this is a
breakdown of the guanamania post-credits
scenes yes I know it's super it's super
early and you may not have seen the
movie yet but we wanted this video to be
here for anyone who did see quantumania
on opening day and anytime after because
we know how fun it is to come out of
these Marvel movies chatting about the
end credit scenes and hushed voices in a
cinema Lobby we thought it'd be helpful
to have us in that conversation oh look
it's standing for Creed Three and
someone took Jonathan the major shirt
again why can't I look away from it I'm
stalling to give you one last chance to
pause this video If you haven't seen
quantumania yet because uh you're gonna
have some questions okay Ant-Man the
Watson Mania has two post-credit scenes
and it is the first time in years for a
Marvel movie that they are both
nerdgasms of World building that get us
equally hyped for what comes next in the
MCU I'm gonna break them both down in
this video but tomorrow February 17th
will be the official launch of our new
channel the Deep dive in which you'll be
able to watch a slate of five premium
videos including my live breakdown of
guanamania where I will Analyze This
movie in real time with you so please
subscribe at Deep dive INR and join me
tomorrow and you can support our growing
new rockstars Network by getting our
awesome merch like this Quantum media
inspired shirt Randy turtle or something
for more deep dive collection all this
stuff at nerdrive.shop okay quantumania
ends with Scott and hope successfully
defeating Kang in the quantum realm
disabling his multiversal engine core
with both growing and shrinking pen
particles and forcing Kang into that
Vortex it creates sucking him down to
who knows like it could be dead but we
saw essentially the same thing happened
to Darren cross and he came out as Modoc
so presumably Kang is in another
probability storm with thousands of
other kings but Jessica and Tommy have
an ending explained video coming up that
will go into all of that the movie ends
with Scott looping back to a San
Francisco routine and a birthday party
for Cassie haunted by the fear that by
defeating Kang he left the world
vulnerable to the Kang Dynasty and in
this verse post-credit scene that is
exactly what we see a vast Arena filled
with shouting Kings each teleporting in
from squares of white light this scene
is taken directly from some famous comic
imagery 1988's Avengers 292 written by
Walt Simonson penciled by John bashima
that's a name or storyline but it
features a cutaway in which Kang is
summoned before the Council of kangs the
council began had been introduced a few
years prior 1986's Avengers 267 but this
is the first time we see the raucous
Amphitheater full of thousands of Tanks
all excited to add another to their
ranks now the arena in this scene is
something closer to a Roman Coliseum
Kang's appear in the stands and in the
pit most wear shades of green but there
is a bright red one right in the middle
who I think could be the king
incarnation of the Scarlet Centurion we
see a few massive statues towering over
this Arena similar to the Kang statue
that looms over the TVA now but rather
than just an uncovered Jonathan major's
face these statues are all helmeted the
sky behind them is purple streaked by
lightning in a sacred timeline snakes
behind the clouds then we cut to three
VIP kangs one says so the exiled one is
dead and from the Shadows steps forward
a Kang dressed as an Egyptian pharaoh
this is Pharaoh Rama Tut technically the
earliest known form of Kang in the
Marvel Comics though when he appeared in
1963's Fantastic Four number 19 as a
time traveler who took over ancient
Egypt he wasn't yet established as Kang
he was later retconned to be the same
person ramatut asked are you sure he's
dead now Rama top was actually
referenced in episode 3 of Moon Knight
art on the back of that Egyptian kid's
jacket taken directly from Mike Del
Mundo's illustration of Kang as ramadet
in 2017's Avengers Unleashed here the
lines on ramadet's face are golden
Kang's cheek scars are one of the many
Mysteries I'm going to be exploring in a
special Deep dive into quantumania that
I'm doing on the new channel next week
in addition to breaking down the Easter
eggs of the movie on the main new
rockstars Channel tomorrow this movie's
got a lot going on with it it deserves
to be explored in several different ways
in this scene responding to ramatut is
another Kang in a glowing futuristic
suit with a bald head fused with cyborg
Parts it looks like he says if it wasn't
true I wouldn't call you this can could
be a few different figures I mentioned
scarless Centurion but Scarlet Centurion
has a red medieval attire and this
futuristic Kang really strikes me as
either Kang Prime who is a dominant Kang
at the end of time at the Avengers fight
in Avengers Unleashed or maybe the adult
Kang that iron lad faces off against
iron lad being a teenage Nathaniel
Richards who hasn't become king yet this
could be the adult King that he faces
that causes him to go back in time and
join the Young Avengers I'm gonna call
this one and future Kang the once in
future king I know I know future Kang is
silly because they're all Timeless kangs
I just think they created a new Kang
they said if this one to fight people
like the Young Avengers in Iron lad
because that body suit really does look
like what Iron Man wears so Rama taunts
him it really must eat you up then
you're not the one who killed him
referring to that exiled King the
Conqueror but a third Kang steps Out of
the Shadows with a raspy voice none of
us killed him they did this gang is
definitely immortus who has also
originally introduced as a separate time
manipulating villain in 1964's Avengers
number 10 but was later retconned as yet
another form of Kang he's known for his
tall headpiece his dramatic mustache in
that eight-pointed star emblem now if
you look closely Rama Tut bows his head
in respect to immortus but future Kang
does not he seems to have an ego on him
but immortus does seem to be the Elder
of the three and note that of these
three only Rama Tut has facial scars
Immortal says they're beginning to touch
the Multiverse and if we let them they
will take everything think we built so
let's stop wasting time he opens window
to show the flowing sacred timeline
outside but with split branches sneaking
off in every direction forming what we
assume are incursions it's a close-up
version of the wide shot that we saw in
the Loki finale when another one of
their variants he who remains was killed
by Sylvie and the sacred timeline split
just like this earlier in this movie
Kang explained to Janet Van Dyne that
the members of the Kang Dynasty played
with the Multiverse like children and
caused incursions and he started the war
with them to put an end to this but
really it sounds like every Kang hates
each other they blame the others for
these incursions and are equally to
blame themselves for causing more
incursions but immortus's line suggests
their concern over what Loki and Sylvie
did when Dr Strange and Peter Parker did
with their spells opening up cracks in
the Multiverse which had a similar
purple cloudy background as we see now
and of course what Wanda maximoff and Dr
Strange did in Multiverse Madness in
those sorcerer's case it was using the
dark hole to dreamwalk into the bodies
of their multiversal selves causing what
Reed Richards referred to in that movie
as incursions now remember Reed Richards
is the ancestor of Nathaniel Richards
AKA Kang and all of these kangs in this
Arena appear from glowing Square shaped
portals just like the blue portal that
Reed used in Multiverse of Madness so
immortus turns away from the window
saying we're late future Kang raises his
voice to him how many did you call an
immortus response
and then we're back in the arena pit
where more and more Kang's teleport in
by the dozens most of them wear a
combination of green and purple robes
but one turns toward us on the left in
dark gray armor maybe someone from
Scarlet centurion's era perhaps but
again I think that red one we saw
earlier in the first wide shot with
Scarlet Centurion then there's another
with long hair who gets real pumped up
and behind him to the right fascinating
one this guy wears a modern slim
corporate suit I think this might be Mr
Griffin CEO of Chang Enterprises q-e-n-g
this is the Kang variant 2 in the comics
bot Stark Tower and we saw in the void
of Loki episode 5 a pruned Avengers
Tower with Q Eng written on it so the
long-running mystery of who bought
Avengers Tower after Tony Stark and the
Avengers moved out in the MCU I believe
the answer is Mr Griffin and Kang
Enterprises this fella right here one
version of Kang hidden in the background
of corporate America in the present-day
MCU trying to get his hands on every
piece of Stark Tech that he can I'm
gonna make a [__] ton of Theory videos
about this guy in particular if you were
still joked as I was by Quantum media's
post-credit scenes and wanted to I don't
know rush to your blue dungeon and
record a video about it the best way to
move anywhere would be on a hovsco
e-bike hopsco can zip you around town at
up to 28 miles per hour with pedal
assist the bike has a range of up to 60
miles throttle only and a range of up to
80 miles if you don't mind pumping your
legs a bit even if you live in hilly San
Francisco like me or Scott Lang do
you'll have a 7-speed three-wheel
shifter making uphill riding smooth and
easy there's a torque sensor on most of
the bikes that provides Instant Power
when you apply pressure to the pedal
great for starting from stop on a hill
it's also very fun let's crank this baby
up
the hills of San Francisco have met
their match the LCD digital panel is
easy to read even when it's bright out
the 48 volt Samsung LG lithium battery
will keep your bike and your flashlight
going and oh my god did I mention how
fun it was I found an Easter egg the
Easter eggs how lovely this bike is to
ride all hopsco e-bikes come with a
two-year warranty and free shipping but
they are hooking up new Rockstar's
viewers with a special offer if you
enter promo code rockstar1 at checkout
you'll get a free accessory that's not a
battery or a charger with any e-bike
purchase so you can customize your bike
with a set of fenders a mounted basket a
rear rack and more to get your e-bike
and free accessory today go to
hopsco.com and use promo code rockstar1
at checkout and don't forget it's so fun
and then we cut to the stance where
thousands of other tanks are pointing
down to the pit jumping in excitement
like Kansas City fans who can't act like
they've been here before though there is
a green cloaked Eagles fan Kang turn it
around like my man chill now most of
them are normal looking Jonathan Majors
is this actor going full ham in dozens
of separate takes huge respect to this
actor his energy as each of these tanks
plus the distinct way he voices and
physicalizes each of the three big kangs
like ramadet smirk and mortis's vocal
croak so so impressive and remember
Jonathan Majors also voiced each of the
three time Keepers before we met him as
he remains in fact the three time
Keepers and that fourth mysterious
broken statue in the Loki finale could
be paralleling these three kings and the
fourth exiled King now in this final
shot on the far left is a green skin
extraterrestrial Kang and then on the
right right before we get to Black we
get one gang screaming slapping the
chest of the guy next to him who is a
scaly blue-skinned creature who does
have scar lines I assume he's meant to
be the old-face Kang for that
Amphitheater panel in Avengers 292. so
what we are seeing here is the Kang
Dynasty the thousands of Kings The
Avengers will face in the fifth Avengers
film Avengers King Dynasty coming May
2025. it's gonna be written by this
movie screenwriter Jeff lovnes and
directed by shung Chi director Destin
Daniel [__] now the exact Avengers
lineup of that movie has not been
announced but we have to assume that
Chung Chi will be in the mix so this is
the Kang Dynasty that Kang the
conquerors swore Vengeance against
earlier in the movie before his speech
was cut off by the kanks the ones who
exiled him to the quantum realm who
sabotaged his ship and the ones that he
threatened to burn out of time now
really I think this dynasty is led by
the three in the private room with the
rest of them falling into some kind of
technocratic committee organizational
structure but these three will be the
ones The Avengers have to face in
Avengers 5 and hopefully between now and
then we will see each of these guys
appear as villains and other MCU titles
Beyond Kang Dynasty will be Avengers
Secret Wars in 2026 the conclusion of
the Multiverse Saga and for that I
suspect we will be down to just one Kang
the most powerful Kang which could be
Kang Prime but I suspect it'll be Kang
the Conqueror from this movie after his
further Exile into that multiversal core
and probability storm you can imagine
this guy would be empowered by mastering
a sea of variant Kings inside since he
was the one they exiled he is the Kang
that they all fear now there are a
number of different Kang story lines in
the comics to look at but the one that I
mentioned in 2017's Avengers Unleashed
by Mark Wade is one of the more recent
and comprehensively epic Kang storylines
in which the Avengers try to outthink
keng's timeline manipulation and debate
over whether to kill Kang as a baby this
storyline best fits with the Multiverse
logic of the time runs out slash 2015
Secret Wars events in the comics that
the MCU is clearly adapting in the years
ahead now the second post-credits scene
is equally exciting in my opinion as it
directly sets up one version of Kang
that we will meet in Loki season 2
coming later this year so we find
ourselves at what looks like a 1901
exhibition with a steampunky looking
invention
vintage in the banner on the side reads
Victor timely and his astounding
temporal Marvels timely and Marvel
tempuro meaning time oh my God John of
the major struts out on stage as Victor
timely announcing to the skeptical
looking audience time is everything it
shapes our lives but perhaps we can
shape it another dramatically distinct
performance by Jonathan Majors Victor
timely is another one of Kang's
incarnations when Kang went back in time
to 1901 and founded the town of timely
Wisconsin serving as the town's mayor
and establishing it as an industrial
center by teaching them about robotics
it was upon the site of timely that Kang
built his Fortress city of karnopolis
And Timely not a very subtle name for a
timeline manipulator but in the comics
it was also a nod to Marvel Zone Comics
history before it was called Marvel
Comics the company previously went by
the name of timely Comics so in this
scene watching Victor timely make this
presentation from the audience are Loki
and Mobius in Period appropriate
disguises Loki gasps it's him Mobius
though is unimpressed oh he made him
sound like this terrifying figure and
Loki responds he
he and so we end on what is likely a
scene from Loki season 2. when Loki and
Mobius do some research on all past Kang
sightings throughout history and perhaps
Trace things back to this one inflection
point why would Victor timely be so
important well in the scene he is
pitching a temporal Marvel which based
off of the Ring structure of it looks
like an early model time travel device
or a kind of temporal technology that he
will later use to run the TVA presenting
it like this he reminds us a lot of
Howard Stark at the Stark Expo and later
Howard's son Tony hell maybe Howard
Stark was even inspired directly by
Victor timely as in the comics Victor
timely Jr becomes friends with Phineas
Horton the first human torch and Phineas
Horton was featured at the 1943 Stark
Expo in the first Captain America film
I'm telling you Kay has been here since
the beginning so it looks like this
might have been a potential Branch
timeline that he remains might have
tried to prune in which one of his
variants created this Nexus event by
giving these 1901 folks some Advanced
temporal technology another way of
looking at this go with me on this we
might be looking at origin of the TVA
and these onlookers are his very first
recruits for TVA agents as he
establishes a new hub for temporal Tech
a place that would later get erased from
time could the original Miss minutes
have been one of these proper ladies in
the crowd who makes the mistake of
following the Mysterious Mr timely to a
second location I hope we get to spend a
lot of time with Victor timely a season
one of Loki framed he who remains as a
Wizard of Oz man behind the curtain and
Victor timely was a turn of the century
Thomas Edison figure which very much
evokes the wizard of Oz's Midwestern
real world analog and what was that
character's name again oh yeah Professor
Marvel it is all connected folks and you
heard it here first I cannot wait to
talk about quantumania more both here on
new rock stars with my Easter egg
breakdown coming out tomorrow and on our
new channel the Deep dive with a
quantumania live stream coming noon
Eastern 9 A.M Pacific and an even deeper
analysis of quantumania coming out next
week on the 24th so subscribe to the
Deep dive subscribe to new rockstars
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
foreign